i know that you're playing a lot of
celebrity basketball tournaments these
days isn't that right i am i played
below the rim but i still play the game
yes
okay you know kevin hart who i've gotten
to know a little bit
he used to play in those yes he used to
play he
but he did i understand he doesn't play
anymore but he likes to coach he
well this year in toronto he was the
coach of the west coast celebrity team
and we played against the
uh a canadian team coached by drake uh
kevin has uh put himself on a
self-imposed retirement because he
has been the mvp for the celebrity game
for the last four years
so he was the player slash coach now
normally
you're supposed to look up to your coach
literally and figuratively
yeah it was hard for us to do that as a
team you know kevin is only 411. yeah
yeah yeah so uh and all he did was talk
about himself well you know when i
played
when i won mvp we would get the hell out
of here little [ __ ] boy
but uh he ended up uh we were down at
halftime so he did this dramatic thing
he went into the locker room unbeknownst
to us
and changed into a uniform and came out
to the rocky theme
uh and uh checked himself into the game
they're gonna say
and checked himself into the hospital no
it checked himself into the game did he
play
he did and he used his height to his
advantage but how can i mean he's
how does he yeah how does he how can he
play well at that height well when you
only come up to the kneecaps of the
people that you're playing
you know it's hard for them to get down
to your level so you know he just
dribbled through the legs and you know
yeah he just goes through and they don't
even see him
we don't right and we know we stepped on
him a few times but you know
he's all right